when you have this face to face with
death you instantly lock into what are
you doing with today Ashton Kutcher
sitting down with his brother Michael I
realize that through his celebrity ISM
that I really could use that to to have
a voice the upcoming interview is an
intimate moment for the actor who's
famously private especially when it
comes to family I was born a twin
and from the moment I came into this
world I had to share it with someone but
Oprah Winfrey is known to have her ways
nobody has told you this day is coming
Ashton's opening up on her new series
The checkup when you have this face to
face with death you instantly lock into
what are you doing with today fans are
loving the Brotherly Love moment so ET
is taking a closer look at their
heartwarming Bond
I shared everything I had in this world
and I didn't know that there was another
way
because I always had my brother with me
Ashton and Michael are fraternal twins
Michael was born with Cerebral Palsy
which impacts his speech hearing
mobility in his right hand and vision I
delivered about four pounds I later
dropped to about three pounds my parents
really didn't know if I would survive
through the night and speaking of Oprah
Ashton and his mother sat down with the
former queen of daytime in 2005. Michael
and Ashton have quite a bond Michael he
does have a mild form of cerebral palsy
but the two of them were the most
mischievous guys growing up I mean I
grew up in Iowa you had to find your own
father and when they turned 13 the
family was thrown into crisis back in
1998 I became very ill when Michael had
to undergo an emergency heart transplant
throughout Michael's stay in the
hospital Ashton was always with them
inspired by Michael's ordeal Ashton hit
pause on his early acting dreams before
I moved away from Iowa I was studying
biochemical engineering my goal was to
be a genetic engineer he wanted to help
others and try to find a reason why this
virus struck his brother's heart you
know like you see mothers walk around
with babies in their arms my mom's been
doing that my entire life Ashton first
talked publicly about his brother's
Health struggles in 2003 and during a
chat with the Today Show last year
Michael admitted he was very angry that
his famous sibling shared his disorder
with the world quote I didn't want to be
the face of CP I never talked about it
and he also taught me when I got older
spent years and years feeling bad about
it
our inequalities
he also taught me that he had gifts that
I didn't have extraordinary gifts that I
didn't have
and that every time I felt sorry for him
in life I made him less Michael said he
forgave Ashton and thanked him for
changing his life well I was about 10
years old my brother instilled in me a
message that you know you really can't
lean on your differences or your
disabilities because we all have them we
all have obstacles that that we need to
overcome and we face you're the only one
that can overcome those challenges and
really they're not challenged they're
opportunities
foreign
[Music]